hello youtube and welcome to part 14 not
13 I lied in my last video this is part
14 of let's play amnesia the D the Dark
Descent ah my brain is broken okay going
in these three rooms here yeah yeah
intelligent use ah boy Oh Daniel you
bastard oh hey that's useful
Oh Oh No yeah
Oh
okay all right
shut up Daniel you're an evil bastard ah
I know exactly where to look cause I am
so take a smart guy ah my chair primary
weapon in defense not good enough
you know how I said the sound effects
were my favorite part they're starting
to knock all
[Music]
yikes right
I'm gonna walk away from that visual
worst part is I think all of these
torture methods are real I'm pretty sure
every room has a new one they will use
that for a lot of work or for saps
victus aww oh oh oh no oh no no no no oh
oh no oh god oh god ah waited for the
victim to drain yep all right that's it
nope nope nope no uh-uh
no no no no no shut up
are you shut up I don't care I'm out of
here
give it back to the knave
oh right where am I going now across the
hall
no there wasn't shut up Agrippa don't
cares about you door who's in here
tinderbox again for you
[Music]
bla bla bla bla
oh oh um oh this is the thing that he
was talking about wasn't fungus barabra
choir vit a any agonize human aha
all right Kirk I have no idea haha ah
the Black Eagle again hmm
huh all right that didn't make much
sense either oh yes please thank you oh
by the choir huh okay what was in here
the fungus all right moving forward here
we go what's who's there
no more torture again you like this
Daniel you like this seeing your work
the blood Ward's are failing yet the
shadow beckons its cry disarmed yeah
might as well just go towards it Oh what
the hell okay sounds good to me
yeah he deserves it
I have to concentrate right
okay okay now once more
withdraw your shadow from my domain okay
well thank you thank you this slowly
opening door Sanda there isn't much time
I can feel it
we must act swiftly
I will do whatever it takes I already
know that Oh more rose petals what is
with the rose petals I don't know my
something I'll be revealed at the end
probably some itching memory scratching
at the back of my mind Oh more choir
okay all right
choir I'm ready to sing ha ha ha
I don't like this
you jerk no no yeah but Daniels a giant
jerk sue yes who knows
ah no no the forger he deserved this ah
oh yeah LD now laudanum
the Beagle bone here Wack Wack Wack Wack
Wack Wack Wack
glowy glowy stone piece over orbit
I was easy no idea where I'm going
whatever though not too tough up losing
sanity of course
Daniel's a big chicken a brave like I am
are you going to what are you doing with
your life doing anything
no killing people Oh
nope I say no no sir not today not today
yeah that's what I thought yeah way too
manly for these guys
not dirty
I'm being intelligent and lighting
torches to show where I've been ah yield
is good for keeping your victim still
during the procedure they can be bound
around the circumference or simply
stretched across oh that's big limbs to
the spokes in real all phantoms all
tools are by this point useful and you
may administer the torture in any way
you like Arthur that's Forte of the
wheel is the gaps when you have decided
that the victim shall die their limbs oh
yeah oh that's great but they'll die too
quickly I mean don't worry the human
body is much more resilient they can
survive for days until they finally
succumb what if I can kill one of the
monsters with this thing
wanna try that I'm taking it with me
my God my God
yeah what's up oh yeah memory at least
he was a murderer mine piece of orb
alright who's who wants them oh man I'm
slowing this thing still who want some
huh yeah I see I'm beating the system
yeah yeah I'm the best bring it on [ __ ]
yeah I got a hammer hammer in your face
[ __ ] up face yeah I'm gonna bring it
bring it on my first victim
who wants some huh is it oh [ __ ] I can't
get the hammer [ __ ] off what the hell oh
no no no no no oh no don't run don't run
what am I supposed to do
don't run alright um I got a pause here
anyway good change over any videos
thanks you all for watching and if you
liked what you saw more is on the way
stick around for part 15 of let's play
amnesia the Dark Descent thank you so
much
goodbye